you talked a little about about
uh
mr depp
purporting to
demonstrate uh jealousy with miss hurt
do you recall that yes i do
and you specifically talked about
mr displaying jealousy regarding uh
the actor james franco correct
now
the very first time
you met
with ms heard
she talked to you about miss franco mr
frank james frank correct
i don't know if it was the first time
but i did ask about some other
relationships so this is the bottom
bottom corner
uh your notes
um and it's under the section of your
notes that's entitled intimate
relationships correct right
and
one of the notes here on the right it
says
jf
that's james james franco right correct
got close but really wanted to to be
with johnny
well it says jeff friends they were
friends all right said friends but you
put him under intimate relationship well
there's a line there because i was
asking specifically about other things
that were allegations in this matter
there's a line there because
you did not believe that they should go
under intimate relationships but it's on
your form
she wasn't telling me that this was an
intimate relationship i queried as to
what's going on with james franco
because that was something that was
raised in this case
and there's a note for december 2050
when they became more friends more
friendly right and that was a period of
time in which
ms heard was married to mr dutt correct
correct
so she became close with mr franco
in december of 2015
and uh
at least you put it under intimate
relationships
with a line differentiating another part
of this document okay
did you provide another header like a
header that says friends
no no
let's look at the next one
the next one says i think it says elon
correct it's elon musk right correct all
right
may 2016.
correct
met ball correct that's a big fancy
party in new york right yes it is
and she says she dated him after johnny
correct
she met elon musk
in may 2016
when did you file the tro
uh the last answer was may 21st i
believe it was may 26th 27th
i'm correct when did she start dating
elon musk
sometime after that
sometime after the tro
i believe so yes okay